MALE SPEAKER: The League!
Please join me in welcoming
Steve Rannazzisi, Katie
Aselton, Mark Duplass,
and Jason Mantzoukas.
How we doing?
JASON MANTZOUKAS: Thank you.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Thanks guys.
MALE SPEAKER: Welcome to Google.
MARK DUPLASS:
[CHANTING] Two beers.
Two beers.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Two
beers down before noon.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: We are wasted.
MALE SPEAKER: So I know
we just talked about.
MARK DUPLASS: You
guys alcoholics too?
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: I saw
you guys eating lunch.
It stinks in here.
KATIE ASELTON: It
smells terrible.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Yeah.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: Did everybody
else have beers at their seats?
Well look under your seats.
KATIE ASELTON: You guys
all get beer at lunch?
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
You get a beer.
MALE SPEAKER: It's just like
a really crazy Oprah show.
KATIE ASELTON:
Beer for everyone.
MALE SPEAKER: So
clearly you guys
have played fantasy football.
We know this.
Everyone asks you this.
MARK DUPLASS: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: So I'm
gonna ask you a question
that maybe you've
been asked a lot.
MARK DUPLASS: Fantasy what?
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, exactly.
Who's your favorite NFL team?
Do you have any agreement?
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Personally?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: The
New York football Giants.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
See I made a really poor life
choice when I was like four
and chose the Jets.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
Yeah, you did.
You made a very poor--
MALE SPEAKER: It's
been really bad.
Really bad.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: You're
probably a Mets fan too then,
right?
MALE SPEAKER: No I
didn't make that mistake.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: OK, cool.
MARK DUPLASS: You Interested
in becoming a quarterback?
They could use one.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm working out.
MARK DUPLASS: OK.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: [INAUDIBLE].
MARK DUPLASS: I'm a Saints fan.
I'm a big Saints fan.
I grew up in New Orleans.
Also, I'm finding myself
falling in love with the Browns
these days.
We were kind of the new
Saints, underdog team--
KATIE ASELTON: He's bandwagon.
MARK DUPLASS: It's time.
It's time.
MALE SPEAKER: Johnny Football.
You love Johnny Football,
the most famous quarterback
in Instagram?
MARK DUPLASS: I like our
cute little hometown hero
there making good.
I want him to stay on.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Yeah.
KATIE ASELTON: I don't
like their pants.
I like the Saints.
I'll stick with them
because they're gold.
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
I'm the person who
doesn't play fantasy football
and doesn't follow football
at all.
But I guess, by default,
being from Boston,
I'm a Patriots fan.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm
sorry to hear that.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: You
want a piece of this?
MALE SPEAKER: So
you guys have a lot
of NFL stars come on the show.
And you guys have had a lot
of guest stars over the years.
Who, out of those guys, really
has the comic timing down,
doesn't really
need much coaching,
that can really maybe
transition, post NFL career
to television the way
Strahan has or anybody else.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
JJ is good, right?
KATIE ASELTON: Yeah.
I think JJ has got a
really nice presence.
And he's real sweet.
And--
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
Take it easy.
Just take it easy, dude.
KATIE ASELTON: I got
a real crush on JJ.
What?
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
He's humongous.
He's like baby Shrek.
KATIE ASELTON: He's ginormous.
I don't think-- The
biggest problem with JJ
is lighting him though
with a normal sized person.
It was virtually impossible to
get a light on him and on Steve
at the same time,
like they're just--
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Yeah.
Although, our heads
are the same size.
KATIE ASELTON: Just
on a different plane.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Yeah.
JJ's great.
Who else has been great?
Terrell Suggs was great.
KATIE ASELTON:
Suggs was awesome.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
Really funny on the show.
We've had him a couple times.
I mean Ochocinco, when
he showed up, was great.
KATIE ASELTON: Now sound
had a real issue with him.
You couldn't hear him.
MARK DUPLASS: You know,
he was super subtle.
He was throwing it away, man.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: And
our poor makeup girl.
Sexual harassment that
went on that week.
He's got like five cell phones.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: Allegedly.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
Allegedly, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Allegedly, he had
five cell phones.
Allegedly, three of
them were burners.
And allegedly, he rented
out a roller skating rink
with Floyd Mayweather
for an hour.
Just the two of them.
To couple skate, I guess.
I don't know.
MALE SPEAKER: Were
you guys not invited?
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
We were not invited.
No, we were not invited.
But he told us all about it.
MARK DUPLASS: There
was also the moment
when he was in just
his underwear playing
slots in the lobby.
KATIE ASELTON: In the casino.
We were in Vegas
shooting that episode.
MARK DUPLASS: While
we were technically
supposed to be shooting
one of his closeups.
KATIE ASELTON: Socks, no shoes--
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
Underwear, no shirt.
He'd just come from a run.
KATIE ASELTON: --a
lot of jewelry,
and a couple cell phones.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Two cell
phones, no short pockets.
No pockets, just
holding cell phones
playing slots at
8:00 in the morning.
MARK DUPLASS: That guy
can come into a character,
let me tell you what.
He can fucking do it.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: He's method.
MALE SPEAKER:
Speaking of committing
to a character, Jason, I
think, as someone said to me,
that some might
say that you have
the most ridiculous
or repulsive character
in the history of television.
And can you explain--
JASON MANTZOUKAS: I'm
taking that as a compliment.
MALE SPEAKER: As you should.
Can you explain the creation
slash evolution of Rafi
and how much you
really steered that.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: Well,
I mean, the creation
was, they wanted me to come in
and play this character who,
in the beginning, they told me
was going to be named Sheldon.
And it was going to be that
arc in that second season which
was, Sofia's brother
comes in the league.
Everybody hates him.
He's in the league
for an episode.
They all kick him out.
He kind of leaves.
And like I said, he's
name was Sheldon.
The Schaffers, who
created The League,
in a lovely way we're like,
what do you want to do.
What version of the
guy do you want to be?
And I was like, oh, I
know what I want to do.
MARK DUPLASS: And here
we are six years later.
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
And somehow Rafi
did not leave after
three episodes
because every show needs
like a sociopathic murder,
possible rapist, possible
hate crimes person--
KATIE ASELTON: With
a real heart of gold.
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
--with a real heart
of gold because that's a thing.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Who
really knows his football.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: He doesn't
know anything about football,
loves the gang, and as
much as they hate him,
he loves them twice as much.
MARK DUPLASS: I remember
the first episode--
I didn't know Jason very
well-- in the first episode,
we were showing up to a party.
And he was supposed
to be our third wheel.
And it was really
supposed to be just
like a joke or two
side character.
And we show up and
we start talking
about how we're
going to get home.
And, literally, in
the first 30 seconds,
Jason's like, I'm driving home.
And I was like, where's
he going to go with this.
So I was like, I'll play along.
I was like, um, well you
can't because you're drinking.
He's like, oh,
that's not a problem.
I'm like, well OK.
So how does this work?
Oh easy, 10 minutes before
I leave, crap out the booze,
eat a mint, and I'm good.
And everybody on set was like,
he's going to be here forever.
We're never letting him leave.
Then the next season,
while improvising,
he comes up with this
idea that Dirty Randy
is his buddy who shoots pornos.
All of a sudden, Seth Rogen
is playing Dirty Randy
and there are multiple
story lines with him.
He makes shit up on set and
then they become like four--
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: It
comes to fruiton, yeah.
MARK DUPLASS: --four
season long stories.
KATIE ASELTON: Yeah.
And all of a sudden
it's a ring tone.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: The
thing they will not
let me do, or they won't
let me follow through on
is my incest storyline that
I've started with Sophia--
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Yeah.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: --which
has gotten pretty far
for television.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
It's got traction though
because they kept
it in this year.
This last episode that
was on two weeks ago--
I think the one
you guys were just
watching-- when you and I are
in the changing room, he's like,
did you ever get one
of Sofia's blow jobs.
And I was like, what?
And he's like, I
heard they're awesome.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: It's, they
are amazing, I've heard.
So yeah.
You're not wrong.
It is a repulsive character
that I have absolute love for.
MARK DUPLASS: And I
don't know if you know
but what's been so great is
that FX has created a brand
new network called FXX so
that they can just brand out
for edgier content.
But what really happened is they
needed their own network just
for Rafi.
You see, he was just
not appropriate for FX.
KATIE ASELTON: We
weren't allowed
to say most of that stuff on FX.
MALE SPEAKER:
Speaking of that, how
do you guys feel about being one
of two shows that's gone to FXX
and actually survived and
that, like really, you guys are
like the brand of that
network at this point.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
It's funny you say that
during contract negotiations.
Um--
MALE SPEAKER: You're welcome?
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Is this
being sent to FX right now?
Everyone there listening, right?
The biggest hurdle
for me, personally,
was like getting my
dad to understand
that it was going to
be on a new number
channel on the television
and what channel
that number was going to be.
And that's what everyone kept--
well what is the new channel?
I mean, I don't know.
They'll figure it out.
They'll tell you.
But for us, I think it's just
we're on a smaller network,
on a sub-- we're on
basic, basic cable now.
KATIE ASELTON: It's
like the kid's table.
We're at the kids table now.
And I have always really
enjoyed the kids table
because then we get to
have our own conversations.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
And people watch us
on Netflix as well too, right?
KATIE ASELTON: I think
people Google us and find out
where to find us.
MARK DUPLASS: Yeah,
nice tie-in bro.
MALE SPEAKER: Very nice.
MARK DUPLASS: Nice.
Fucking, see that?
That was--
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
Or they Bing it.
KATIE ASELTON: No they don't.
No they don't actually.
I've dug-- they don't Bing it.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: I always
say, let's just Bing this
and let's figure it out.
KATIE ASELTON: No.
No.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: We
told you not to say that.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: Where
are we going for dinner?
Dude just Bing it and--
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
Just Bing it.
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
--we'll just relax.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: You
love a good Bing joke
don't you, you nerds.
You love it.
MALE SPEAKER: So changing
the subject ever so slightly.
Of all the expressions
that the show has coined,
which are your favorites?
Whether it be Eskimo brothers--
KATIE ASELTON: Shit sipper.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
KATIE ASELTON: And FYI, just to
put this out in the interweb,
it's shit sipper, not zipper.
It drives me crazy when
people tweet at me--
JASON MANTZOUKAS: Do people
think it's shit zipper?
KATIE ASELTON: Yes.
What the heck does
that even mean?
JASON MANTZOUKAS: That would
be a very difficult thing
to fasten.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Yeah.
KATIE ASELTON: I feel like
that is my most common tweet.
oh, hey shit zipper.
No that's not a--
it's not a thing.
Don't even try and make it one.
It's shit sipper.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Fear boner.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: Murder boner.
MARK DUPLASS: You know, we
had a really complex situation
because we're on
basic cable and we're
allowed to say a lot
of filthy things.
But we were given a very
bizarre list of words
from FX that we can't say.
For instance--
KATIE ASELTON: There's
like two you can't say.
MARK DUPLASS: --you can
call somebody a cocksucker.
That's no problem.
But you cannot
say, suck my cock.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
You can't do it.
The action.
MARK DUPLASS: So,
there's another word--
KATIE ASELTON: It
can't be-- yeah.
There's no action involved.
MARK DUPLASS: There's
no action involved.
Also, it just came
up in the writing
that some people wanted to use
the word retarded in the show.
And that is definitely
not cool these days.
KATIE ASELTON: That's not OK.
MARK DUPLASS: Which I
don't disagree with.
But we had to come
up with a word for it
because the characters
in our show are assholes.
And they use it all the time.
And--
JASON MANTZOUKAS: We
are lovely people.
MARK DUPLASS: Yes,
we are wonderful.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: We are heroes.
MARK DUPLASS: Yeah.
And so Nick Kroll penned
the term frittata.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: It's
almost like he had it prepared.
He's like--
MARK DUPLASS: It
doesn't make any sense.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Yeah,
he was like, no, no.
It's frittata.
That's what we'll go with.
And we're like, yeah.
That works really well.
KATIE ASELTON: It
makes perfect sense.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Yeah.
It's the retarded
of eggs, right?
KATIE ASELTON: I also
really like toilet kitchen.
Toilet kitchen is a good one.
And I feel like I call
places toilet kitchens now.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Does
that answer your question?
MALE SPEAKER: Very much so.
Thank you.
KATIE ASELTON: Shit pig.
Shit pig's another
favorite of mine.
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
Shit pig's fun.
KATIE ASELTON: Yeah.
OK.
I'll keep going.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
We can go all day.
Vaginal hubris was good too.
MALE SPEAKER: I was a big fan
of the height supremacists
the other couple of weeks ago.
It was a good one.
KATIE ASELTON: Screw
those short people.
MALE SPEAKER: So
speaking of short people,
Alina Foley plays
Ellie on the show.
And she's grown up
before our eyes,
as happens on television shows.
But she's grown up on a very
different television show.
And it's a little unusual to
see so much edgier than usual.
How much of Ellie's
character's actually
been influenced by her?
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Her alone?
Well, she's Dave
Foley's daughter,
Dave Foley from
Kids in the Hall.
Which is not to says that
she grew up in filth.
But she understands-- I'm not
trying to pass judgment on him
as a parent.
But I'm saying like
she understands
jokes and humor and comedy.
But we have made
her say some things.
KATIE ASELTON: The
pilot episode, there
is some dispelling of Santa.
There was some talking of-- what
was it in the draft episode?
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
Spoilers for Santa.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Yeah, yeah.
By the way, he isn't coming.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: Just
in case some people
don't know in the room.
KATIE ASELTON: Just
Google it you guys.
There was a pilot episode
that was really the big one,
were Jon Lajoie had
to sit down with her
and be like, I am so sorry that
I have to say these things.
But like, we had fairy
zipper fairy episode
where she's supposed to
walk in on me giving him a--
JASON MANTZOUKAS: What?
What?
A what?
MARK DUPLASS: What?
What?
KATIE ASELTON: --a thing.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Hey.
Hey now.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: A thing?
MARK DUPLASS: What thing?
JASON MANTZOUKAS: This
is on the internet, where
everybody looks at those things.
KATIE ASELTON: Sorry.
It's a blow job.
I was supposed to be
giving him a blowie.
And she walks in the
room and she's like,
what exactly are
they doing in there.
And we were like--
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
Not our department.
That's makeup.
KATIE ASELTON: Talk to your mom.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
Talk to makeup.
MARK DUPLASS: Some shows are
really nice and sensitive
to children being on set.
And they say, you know what?
We'll just let her
be in the green room
while we shoot this side of it.
She seen everything for
better or for worse.
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
They wanted me--
and this I didn't do because
even I was like, Rafi,
this is too much.
They wanted in
this scene last-- I
think it was last season--
where me and baby Geoffrey
are having dump-buddy Bible
study, which is learning
about the Bible while
we're taking shits.
And Rafi shits nude.
Heads up, everybody.
Bing it if you want
to see what's up.
MARK DUPLASS: It was one of your
earliest character decisions,
yeah.
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
Web crawler it.
Don't worry about it.
Anyway, they wanted me
to be on the toilet naked
and for baby Geoffrey
to be on my lap.
And I was like--
KATIE ASELTON: Baby Geoffrey,
by the way, at this point,
was like six.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: I was like,
there is no way this is gonna--
this can't, this can't happen.
This shouldn't happen at all.
And we got into like an argument
about whether that was OK
or not.
And I was like, even for
Rafi, this is too much.
So there are lines guys.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Do you
remember the creepy kid
that they hired to watch us?
There's an episode where--
KATIE ASELTON: I don't know
if they got to work with him.
I think it was just us.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Yeah, he's
in a closet in our bedroom
watching.
He's Ellie's friend.
He's playing hide and seek.
He's really good at it.
And obviously, we're
in our room doing
what grownups do in their room.
And he's watching us.
And the kid they hired--
like most people,
you have to explain to them.
Like, alright, you
going to say Jewhad.
Like to Ellie, like you're
OK, great.
She says it.
This kid had already
like stuff prepared.
He looked at me and he was
like, I know what you're doing.
I know what's going on.
He's really looking at me Jeff.
And he's on his own thing.
This kid was very
gifted in the art
of just being in the
moment, of being real.
KATIE ASELTON: He was like
a little Haley Joel Osment
over there, just
like glaring at us.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Staring
at me while this is happening.
And he was fine with it.
I tried to talk to him.
This is all a joke.
He's like, I'm just
an actor for hire.
I was like, you
are 11 years old.
You should not feel
right with this at all.
Very strange, that kid was.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: Was he in
character the whole time?
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
The whole time.
The whole time he sat there
reading a book by himself.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: He's like the
Daniel Day-Lewis of kid actors?
KATIE ASELTON: I think
he just actually got
the lead in M Night
Shyamalan's movie.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: Oo nice.
That poor kid.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Wierdo.
Yea, we've made kids do
some bad shit on our show.
That's what happens though.
MALE SPEAKER: It's enjoyable.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: Because,
you know what, fuck kids.
Right?
Right Google, right?
Who's with me.
MARK DUPLASS: Fuck
let's go to Bing then.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
Are we supposed
to answer these
questions that are here.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
We've got some
questions on the board.
Why don't we jump towards those.
Ooh, we're opening up here.
Ooh, the first one.
What would be a suitable
Google gift to the Shiva?
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
What's a Google gift?
KATIE ASELTON:
MALE SPEAKER: I guess a gift
that Google can give you.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Money?
Stock options?
What you giving out?
KATIE ASELTON: Just some of
those snacks would be nice.
Coors lite?
MALE SPEAKER: We're two for
three, so that's not bad.
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
And this is a-- just
to clarify-- this is a gift
that's going to the Shiva?
I believe it's a tribute, yes.
MARK DUPLASS: It's and
unclear question guys.
We need some clarification.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
Get it back together.
Yeah, gift going to the Shiva.
KATIE ASELTON: Clarify
[INAUDIBLE] and get back to us.
MALE SPEAKER: We'll
be on lookout.
Did you know that neckties
is a real thing now?
freshneck.com literally calls
itself Netflix for ties.
Who comes up with
Taco Corp ventures
and why has that never
made it to the show?
JASON MANTZOUKAS: Sounds like
they're plugging their product.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Yeah.
Sounds like you did exactly
what they wanted you to do.
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
This is a subtle plug.
And you fell for it.
MALE SPEAKER: You're
welcome Wilson.
MARK DUPLASS: I think if
we click on freshneck.com,
I have a feeling
there's going to be
a video of something
else going on there.
KATIE ASELTON: I was
just going to say--
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: This is
a real lemon party situation.
KATIE ASELTON: --who clicks
on freshneck.com That is--
MARK DUPLASS: I have a
username and password
if we need to use it
for freshneck.com.
$9.99 for the whole year.
Really?
That's really--
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
No, that's per day.
This shit is off the charts.
Dark, dark places.
KATIE ASELTON:
That neck is fresh.
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
It's the dark web.
You have a subscription
to the dark web, right?
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: It's
the sub-internet, yes.
MALE SPEAKER: Speaking of Taco
Corp-- I know John's not here
but is he more like high
Taco or non-high Taco?
KATIE ASELTON: Non-high Taco.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Yeah.
He's a smart kid
from Montreal who's
been saddled with
us as cast members.
So yeah, he's not an imbecile.
No he's not.
KATIE ASELTON: And doesn't
dress like a frittata
from the '70s at all.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: I like
that a lot of questions
about this show have to mean
that everybody has to be like,
John is not an imbecile.
Jason is not a monster.
No, they're just normal.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
But NIck is a dick.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, that said,
one of the other questions
here is, which member The League
is most like their character.
And which one is least
like their character.
So, clearly you're
not a monster.
But is anyone--
KATIE ASELTON: I would
say Steve this probably
most like his character
in that he's not
particularly great
at fantasy football.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: Whoa.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Wow.
What is this, a roast?
JASON MANTZOUKAS: Hey now.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
You Jeff Ross?
All right.
I feel somewhat close
to my character.
I'm married.
I have two kids in real life.
And I play fantasy football.
But I'm not a lawyer.
MARK DUPLASS: Steve.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Oh God.
I'm so depressed about football.
MARK DUPLASS: You're scared
of that fucking bird.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: I'm
so depressed about about--
MARK DUPLASS: Did
anybody see the episode
with the bird in it?
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Oh,
I am afraid of birds.
MARK DUPLASS: Steve was
terrified of the goddamn bird.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
Nobody tells me
they're going to have a
fucking bird until we show up.
This thing's got no soul.
The eyes were dead.
It's just that they come at you.
And they put their
feathers up real big.
And you don't know
what's going on
in their fucking bird brains.
I don't when it's
going to attack.
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
What's interesting
is we recently shot
a scene with a bear.
And you were not
afraid of that bear.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
Not afraid at all.
A grizzly bear, eight
feet, 750 pounds,
I told it to go fuck itself.
But birds--
MARK DUPLASS: And
it did, right away.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: It finger
blast itself behind a trailer.
I was like, what?
JASON MANTZOUKAS: Lady bear.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
Yeah, lady bear.
Thank you Jason.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: If you want to
see what that looks like guys,
just Google it.
MALE SPEAKER: Freshneck.com.
So, solo projects
aside, if each of you
could star in another TV show
right now, which would it be
and why?
What are you loving out there?
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Is
Real Housewives of Jersey--
can I sign up for that.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: I believe
there are some openings.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Yea,
the Giudices are gone.
I'm in.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: Oh.
Oh, too soon.
Oh, no.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Oh
my God, tax evasion.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: How dare you.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
How can you talk
about tax evasion like that?
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
They are beloved.
This is New York.
911.
MARK DUPLASS: But
murder boner is fine.
Don't worry about murder boner.
MALE SPEAKER: Why don't we open
it up to the live audience.
There are two microphones
in each aisle.
KATIE ASELTON: We're not
scared of you guys either.
Just to say that.
MALE SPEAKER: If you guys want
to make a little organized
line, ask a couple
questions to the cast.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Perfect.
Look at that.
That's great.
Oh, here she comes.
MARK DUPLASS: Here she comes.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
There she comes--
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
Better be good.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
--Ms. Google.
AUDIENCE: So, the
show is hilarious.
However, whenever I talk about
this with my girlfriends,
I always feel like Jenny
is not a real person
in any sort of way, even
like a caricature of a woman.
So, I'm curious to hear whether
you have female writers.
And just, Katie, what your
perspective on the character
is.
And is she meant to be
like this fantasy person.
KATIE ASELTON: We
do have-- the show
is created by a couple,
Jackie in Jeff Schaffer.
Jackie is a woman.
And she writes a lot for Jenny.
And Jenny is very
much like Jackie.
But I don't think Jenny is real.
I mean I think
there's a reason why
Jenny doesn't have
any girlfriends.
She's not a particularly
nice, warm, comforting woman,
you know.
I think Jenny has got a lot
of wish fulfillment for guys.
I think she's sort of
like the dream wife who
loves to talk about football,
and have sex, and screw
the kids, and like, whatever.
And she's fun with
the guys and--
MARK DUPLASS: Wait Jenny
has sex with her kids?
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Whoa.
We did not talk about this.
MARK DUPLASS: Did
I miss something?
JASON MANTZOUKAS: It's in there.
But I think she is a
little-- but I mean, look,
I have met so many women after
doing the show where like,
I'm Jenny.
I am so Jenny.
I think it's a little
Sex in the City.
We all thought we were Carrie.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: We did.
Ugh.
I thought I was.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: I
thought I was Miranda.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
The amount of dresses
I bought the late '90s.
KATIE ASELTON: But yeah.
I personally don't
really relate to Jenny.
I think Jenny is like me if
I were to turn everything up
to a 15.
You know she's
super competitive.
I'm competitive but I'm
not that competitive.
And she's super sassy.
And I'm sassy but
I'm not that sassy.
And she loves to have sex.
And I like to have
sex but not that much.
No.
But I think you're not--
MARK DUPLASS: Erm.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: I would
have left that last part out.
Hey Katie, I would have
left that last part out.
KATIE ASELTON: I think you
and your friends are not alone
in the world.
You're OK if you don't totally
think that-- you're fine.
You're fine.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
You're normal.
KATIE ASELTON: Sleep well.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: You are
right in the sense the Jenny is
the only character that
doesn't seem real on the show.
KATIE ASELTON: I think
we're all sort of extreme.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: Everybody
else on this show is--
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
Super grounded.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: --very
grounded, very naturalistic.
We recognize them all.
Jenny though, crazy.
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
Love the show guys.
You do an episode
with Jay Cutler.
And he's got a reputation
for being a huge asshole.
And I want to know what
you guys think of him.
KATIE ASELTON: I actually
thought he was really nice.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
KATIE ASELTON: Yes.
He was really nice.
He was reluctantly there.
KATIE ASELTON: He
very clearly said, I'm
only here because Kristin
asked me to be here.
And we're like, that's cool.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
Kristin Cavallari
did an episode the year before.
And then we thought it'd be
really fun to bring her back
and maybe have Jay come back.
And we could do a thing where
we all go to school together.
And she asked him.
And he came back.
And he was great, all day.
KATIE ASELTON: He
was like, I don't
know why you guys do this.
It's so boring.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: It's boring.
KATIE ASELTON: And
we're like, yeah.
Sometimes it's boring.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
This is how it is.
KATIE ASELTON: There
a lot of waiting.
And he's like, this is-- I
mean, he wasn't a jerk about it
though.
He was nice.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Yeah.
It's not his thing.
He doesn't like to talk
in front of people.
If he wasn't a huge
quarterback, he
would be a quiet person
who kept to himself.
MARK DUPLASS: If you
guys keep talking,
you're basically just going to
say that Cutler's an asshole.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
No, he's not--
MARK DUPLASS: You might
want to just-- everybody
sees where this is going.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
Super good dude.
Loved being there.
Real piece of shit.
Loved it.
MARK DUPLASS: An
individual for sure.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: Human
being on the Earth.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Beat of
his own drummer, I guess.
Hates music.
Fuck.
No, he's great.
He really is.
He's a great person.
And I love him.
He's got great hair.
And I asked who his
hairstylist was.
MARK DUPLASS: Just stop it.
Stop.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
And he gave it to me.
And it doesn't come out as good.
Next question.
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hey everyone's.
So Paul Scheer, who
plays Andre sort of--
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Who?
JASON MANTZOUKAS: Boo.
Boo.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Answer the question
MARK DUPLASS: He's at
fucking Bing right now.
KATIE ASELTON: Yeah.
He's doing Yahoo
talks as we speak.
AUDIENCE: Never mind.
Beginning of the season, he was
having a bit of a comeuppance.
Turned out to be kind of BS.
Does he, or do you
as characters ever
mind being crapped on
variously when you're filming.
Afterwards, do you ever
take it home with you.
MARK DUPLASS: We prefer
the term, shat upon.
And it's the most
fun on the show,
when you're getting shit on.
That is really where the
attention and the love
comes from in this weird, moral
universe that we have created.
And Paul gets it the most.
And he's so very good at
inviting it onto himself.
I mean, I remember we opened
last season at the bar.
And we're always
terrible when we first
start shooting the show.
Everybody's rusty.
The first takes are horrible.
And something came up about
eating corn and corn cobs.
And you just see
Paul's eyes light up.
And I know in his mind
he's just like, I'm
going to get myself
into a place where
I talk about how much I
love eating corn cobs.
And everybody's just going
to pile on the dick jokes.
And it's going to be
magic for everyone.
It's going to be
dick joke Disneyland.
And he just does it.
KATIE ASELTON: A lot of
it does come from Paul,
like the spunk when he
was doing the marathon.
Spunk was all in.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Sports
Performance Utility Nutrition
Kick.
He came up with that so quickly.
KATIE ASELTON: In the moment.
That was great.
And that's him.
But it's him being
like, here you go guys.
It's a nice platter.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: And by the
way, as a person who's getting
ripped on a lot this year on
the show, it's not as much fun
as it looks.
And Paul has done a unbelievable
job of accepting that ridicule
and just gives it
back with earnest.
He really does.
He thinks that it's
just you proving
that he's one of the guys.
It's beautiful.
It really is.
MARK DUPLASS: The most
used quote on the show
is Paul Scheer saying, Ha ha ha.
Laugh all you want.
That's like the most useful
piece of dialogue on the show.
MALE SPEAKER: So would
you say that Paul
is the one who sets
the table the most
when it comes to
those kind of things.
MARK DUPLASS: Yeah.
I think so.
I think that Jesus Christ
laid himself on the cross.
And it's nothing
compared to what
Paul Scheer has
done for The League.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: That's right.
The League is bigger than Jesus.
MARK DUPLASS: That's right.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: Boom.
MARK DUPLASS: You heard it here.
Bing.
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So speaking
of Andre, I'd
like to pull an
Andre and-- advice.
Should I give up Ben
Tate for Percy Harvin?
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Ben
Tate for Percy Harvin.
AUDIENCE: Do you guys all
play fantasy football, Rafi?
JASON MANTZOUKAS: I don't but
everybody else can weigh in.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
That's tough.
KATIE ASELTON: Go for it.
KATIE ASELTON: No.
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
You know what, if you
want an uninformed decision--
what are their names?
AUDIENCE: Ben Tate
and Percy Harvin.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: Pussy?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: The
second man's name is pussy?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: You
gotta choose pussy bro.
AUDIENCE: Every time, yeah.
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
Always choose pussy bro.
MARK DUPLASS: And the best
part about fantasy football
is that, that's just as good of
advice as coming from Matthew
Barry who knows everything
because nobody knows anything.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Ben
Taint or Pussy Harvin?
Which one--
JASON MANTZOUKAS: Oo.
Now we're getting into
a real tough spot.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
Taint or Pussy?
Ben Taint or Pussy Harvin.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: You're putting
me into a real tough spot
choosing between
taint and pussy.
MALE SPEAKER: Jason,
honestly, is he a plant?
JASON MANTZOUKAS: I
wish he was a plant.
That would be amazing.
What if everybody just
started setting up
jokes for me, all the questions.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Let's jump onto
the screen again.
Can we scroll down a
little bit, Jordan?
Ba, ba ba, ba ba.
On behalf of women
everywhere-- Whoa.
Sorry.
Thank you bringing back
Adrien Bro-- and Adam
KATIE ASELTON: Adrian Brody
has not yet been on the show.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you for
bringing Adam Brody back
to prime time television.
KATIE ASELTON: You're welcome.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: And
then we fucking killed him.
MALE SPEAKER: Take him away.
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
So you're welcome.
You're welcome women.
KATIE ASELTON: Such a
beautiful corpse though.
He was so handsome
in that casket.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Please
have Gronk at the next draft.
OK, who the fuck would want
to shoot with Rob Gronkowski?
You telling me you
want Rob Gronkowski
over here hanging out with you?
The guys a neanderthal.
OK.
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
Steve Rannazzisi.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: There it is.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: We're
not going to have Gronk.
MALE SPEAKER: So
that bridge is burnt.
MARK DUPLASS: On this
episode of Making Friends
with Steve Rannazzisi--
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Yeah, no.
MARK DUPLASS: --Rob
Gronkowski and Jay Cutler.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: I love Jay.
MALE SPEAKER: When will Andre
start his own fashion blog.
Unlikely to happen.
No.
KATIE ASELTON: Season 10.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Oh somebody
in the front row just said, oh,
poor Andre.
Yeah.
You feel bad for him, right?
JASON MANTZOUKAS: But
would you sleep with him?
No?
She said, no.
MALE SPEAKER: So I
actually want to go back
to the Rafi, Dirty Randy thing.
The live alone
episode last year,
that was one of the most
mad things I've ever seen.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: If you say so.
MALE SPEAKER: When do
we get another one?
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
It just happened.
It came out a
couple of weeks ago.
Part two was-- three weeks ago?
KATIE ASELTON: It was a prequel.
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
It was the prequel.
It was the origin story
of Rafi and Dirty Randy.
And it takes place in
a mental institution.
KATIE ASELTON: It's a real
heart breaker you guys.
I'm not kidding.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
It was so much fun
to watch because we
don't get that script.
I had no idea beyond what Jason
told me about that episode.
Besides that, we were in
that for that one little
quick scene.
And then watching it, it's like
watching a show that you're on,
that you got paid to be on,
that you have no idea what
the fuck is going to go
on or how these two met.
So that episode is
always my favorite one
to watch because
I literally have
no idea what's going to happen.
KATIE ASELTON: And also, you
see Jason without a beard.
And what the world doesn't
know, but you can Google,
is how dashing handsome he is.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
Oh, handsomefaces.com?
KATIE ASELTON: That
jawline under that
beard-- he's a
Grecian god you guys.
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
Oh yeah, no beard.
No beard for the first
time in, I think,
seven years for all of 25
seconds of screen time.
No, those episodes are
incredibly fun to do.
And they are incredibly
polarizing to the audience.
As I'm sure for those
of you here we've
seen them, who are
fans of the league,
it is very much-- people
are either like, oh my god
this is the funniest
episode, or, fuck you.
You ruined my show.
MARK DUPLASS: And it
is 50-50 for sure.
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
It is very much so.
Yeah.
People are furious.
And I get excited when I
know it's about to air.
And I'll kind of
go on Twitter just
to see what people are
saying about The League.
And the cold open comes on.
And it's just me and Seth.
And immediately people
are like, fuck no.
And then the next
one would be like--
MARK DUPLASS AND JASON
MANTZOUKAS: fuck yeah!
JASON MANTZOUKAS: And then
it's just hatred and love,
every other one.
It's pretty fantastic.
In what others show do they give
two, completely side characters
an entire episode of
their own to do whatever
the fuck we want,
which is madness.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: It is.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: The
idea that, here's a show.
It's about fantasy football.
And it's about this
group of friends.
And everybody's great.
And some are married.
Some are single.
Blah, blah, blah.
Except for this one episode--
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
Not this week.
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
--that's about murder,
vigilante justice, more murder,
pornography, drugs, bath salts.
Like crazy, absolute insanity.
MARK DUPLASS: And
that's why it's
a very special
episode of The League.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Absolutely.
MALE SPEAKER: Yes sir.
AUDIENCE: So hello.
Thank you guys for coming today.
This is great.
I had a question about
Jon Lajoie, aka Taco.
Before he joined the show--
MARK DUPLASS: By the
way, congratulations
on getting his name right.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
Yea good job.
MARK DUPLASS: Most
people say Jon La-joe--
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: La-joy.
MARK DUPLASS: La-jo-ee.
So well done.
AUDIENCE: That's right.
Thank you.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
Are you Canadian?
AUDIENCE: I'm not.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Good.
AUDIENCE: Is that a problem?
KATIE ASELTON: It's a plus.
AUDIENCE: So he was a
YouTube star on his own
before you actually
joined the show
and had a bunch of hits
like every day guy--
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Normal guy.
AUDIENCE: -everyday normal guy.
Sorry.
So when he joined
the show, I know
he brought some of that
element to the cast in how
he performed.
How much of the stuff
that he does on his own
does he bring to the
table and puts it
into the show versus
what's written for him.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: I think
he's finishing up a soundtrack.
I think we're putting
out a leak soundtrack
that Jon has been
putting together
for a while with
Jackie and Jeff.
So yeah.
As far as music's concerned,
Jon takes the lion's share
of that work.
I think he kind of-- they
will come to him and be like,
hey we have an idea for this.
Would you want to write a song.
And earlier on, I think
that's how it worked.
I think we've kind of gone away
from him just performing songs
in the last couple of years.
But we have enough to,
I guess, make an album.
So Jon's kind of curating that
and putting that together now.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: A lot of
that driven off of his presence
on YouTube, which
is owned by who?
AUDIENCE: Bing.
Bing.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Yahoo.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
KATIE ASELTON: Thank you.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
Is that a plug
for your own self, your
own company right there?
A roundabout way to be like,
yeah, YouTube too motherfucker.
MALE SPEAKER: Yes sir.
AUDIENCE: So often you guys try
to tie in actual things that
happened in the NFL since
your show has nothing
to do with anything about it.
How does some of the real life
things, like Adrian Peterson
getting kicked out, affect
the show in a season
as it's currently going along.
And how do you adjust for it?
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
We, this year-- yeah.
A lot of shit
happened this year.
KATIE ASELTON: So much
material to work with.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
Sometimes we touch
on things in our own
little way, very subtly.
And then sometimes we'll
hit it over the head.
We talk about, this year,
domestic sexual abuse
between Jenny and I. And then
we have figured out a way
to hit upon the recent events
of what's happened in the NFL.
And we can't give it
away, but you'll see.
It's pretty funny.
KATIE ASELTON: It
is pretty funny.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
It's pretty funny.
And--
JASON MANTZOUKAS: The way that
what's happening in the NFL
is funny.
Yeah exactly.
Yes.
MARK DUPLASS: I guess
you'd call hilarious.
Right guys?
Google?
Good comedy.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: I mean, for
the most part, our creators,
Jeff and Jackie, will come up
with different ways they want
to touch on stuff at
the beginning of year.
But we're still shooting
the show right now.
We haven't even shot the
last two or three episodes.
So stuff that happens
today, we can kind of
find a way, if we can,
to fit in later on.
So we are somewhat current
to what's happening now.
So we'll wedge in our own
little opinions here and there.
But for the most
part, we'll just
stick to the fucking
comedy, make it funny.
MARK DUPLASS: Well
Jeff, our creator,
he's really good with not just
fantasy football knowledge
but just knows
the NFL very well.
So he'll make these
guesses occasionally
where he was like, I feel
like Darren Sproles is going
to have a hell of a
fucking game in this week.
And so when he wrote the episode
about the height supremacists,
it was kind of predicated
on Darren Sproles having
a pretty good week, which you
took an educated guess about.
Turned of the guy ran from
180 yards and it worked out.
And then, occasionally,
what we'll do is,
we'll shoot things in a way that
you have some backs of heads,
like shooting my conversation
with Steve, shooting this way.
And we'll do like three
options of wide receivers
that we think are going
to shit the bed this week.
So we'll be like, do a
version with Mike Tolbert,
do a version with
this person, whatever.
And then you try to pick one
of those three that works.
And then if nothing
works, we go in
and do ADR, which is where
we actually just dub over
a player's name and try
and create some relevance.
So that's sort of the
specific NFL tie-in of it.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: We guess.
MALE SPEAKER: Very interesting.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MARK DUPLASS: It changes.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
Depends on who you are.
MARK DUPLASS: The
question's about the improv.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: 100 percent
at that end of the table.
100 percent.
KATIE ASELTON: Jay Cutler
is totally scripted.
MARK DUPLASS: Jay
Cutler is so nice
that we scripted
everything for him.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
What a great guy.
He really is.
I'm not kidding.
No.
But I remember the
Kluneberg episode
where we had the painting.
I remember-- this has nothing
to do with staying on script--
but they were like, Jason,
we only have one of these.
OK, so let's not ruin this one.
Great, great.
No problem.
Got it.
Let's not ruin the-- Action.
Comes in, takes the Kluneberg
and smashes it over his knee
into 100 pieces,
continually smashing
freaking breaking it up.
And at the end, it was just
like, I hope we got it.
We got it?
I hope we got it.
And we got it.
We got it.
Every time we get it.
But we don't know if we got it.
That's the thing.
We're not sure.
KATIE ASELTON: We get
outlines for the episodes.
And those consist of a
paragraph, two paragraphs,
sometimes more, of what's
happening in the scene.
And sometimes there's a
line written in there.
A lot of the times, the dialogue
is just sort of left up to us.
MARK DUPLASS: Or they'll
have good joke ideas
that they can pinpoint
for us in there.
And they'll lay
them in the outline.
KATIE ASELTON: But
most of the time,
it's all found in the moment.
And then once you
hit on it, then
you do that a couple of times.
You work out the kinks.
MARK DUPLASS: As
we've gone on, we've
realized that when you
have a six person scene,
it's probably
better to script it
a little bit more because
it's informational usually.
And you're trying to get the
machinations of the story out.
And it just takes forever
if you try and move around.
But when it's a really
great two person scene,
and you just throw
three cameras on it.
You've got a close up on
one person, a close up
on the other person, and
then a two shot of them.
Then it's just like--
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
Have fun for an hour.
MARK DUPLASS: --let it rip.
And you're going to
get whatever you want.
KATIE ASELTON: And those,
truthfully, for all of us
are our favorite scenes.
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
And that's the stuff
that I feel like, the
discovery that you
find through improvising
with people, who are also
great improvisers, are
the moments and the beats
and the jokes that
are oftentimes
the stuff that I feel
like people love.
Because what you're watching
is the joy and delight
of us discovering.
And I actually feel that
is a weird electric moment.
What's that?
KATIE ASELTON: Michael
Jackson's dead.
That moment between you
and Nick was one of-- it
still plays as one of
the funniest moments
I've ever seen.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: And they cut
together-- the Schaffers cut
together a thing that is me and
Nick trying to get through it.
Which is very funny
because the scene was--
this is a couple seasons ago--
and the scene is just Nick
and I in his study.
And he's asking me to protect
his balls because it's scrote
season.
And everybody's punching
each other in the balls.
And he wants me-- that's
all that was written, right.
Ruxin wants Rafi to
protect his balls.
OK.
So we do a couple of
takes of just that.
Oh, don't worry.
MARK DUPLASS: Don't every write
just that with Jason Mantzoukas
in your scene because
you're just asking for it.
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
And then through that
takes it became-- it starts
with me improvising like,
oh I'm Kevin Costner.
Your balls are Whitney Houston.
I'll be your ballsy guard.
Ha ha ha.
That cracks us up.
OK.
So we'll do that.
So we get that far again--
because the surprise of it
always makes us laugh.
And so OK, ha ha.
We'll go again and that's
what I'm going to do, so good.
So I'm Kevin Costner, your
balls are Whitney Houston.
I'm going to be
your ballsy guard.
And then he goes-- oh, no.
I'll be your ballsy guard,
Kevin Costner, Whitney Houston.
And then Nick goes, RIP.
And I go, what?
No!
This now makes us
laugh hysterically.
The discovery that Rafi doesn't
know that Whitney's dead is--
we can't get through it.
We can't get through it.
Nick has to get up and
leave the room for awhile.
MARK DUPLASS: Makeup
touch ups for the tears.
Yeah.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: And we're
sweating now under the lights.
And we're laughing.
And we think it's so funny.
The crew is furious.
Why the fuck do you
think you're so funny.
Oh, it's awful.
So then we finally get to a
place where we can get through,
oh no.
Whitney Houston is dead.
And then, oh no!
Whitney's dead.
Oh God.
How is Michael
Jackson taking it?
This is categorically
impossible to get through.
We end up shooting
that line with Nick
out of the room
because for a while,
he has to leave his seat.
And he's just off camera,
out in the back over here
going, [CHUCKLE].
MARK DUPLASS: Like Blair
Witch in the corner.
And I'm like, I can
still see you shaking.
You have to get out of here.
So to finish this-- so that's
the way The League works best,
building on-- There's an
idea that is already funny.
And then through improv, you
find a better, and a newer,
and a heightening-- a way to
heighten through the scene
and build something that started
as a very small throwaway bit
and becomes a very funny piece.
And that's what I think
is great about The League.
Eat shit.
MALE SPEAKER: Well,
thank you very much.
Unfortunately, we're
about to run out of time.
So if you guys don't
mind hanging out
for just two minutes.
If we can take some pictures
with you, would that be cool?
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Sure.
JASON MANTZOUKAS: I feel bad
for this girl right here though.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI: Yeah. she
stood there the whole time
while Jason rambled on.
MARK DUPLASS: She's ready.
She's ready.
So I'm a big fan.
Thanks for coming.
And this is a very
specific question.
But I've noticed that a lot
of the actors from The League
have also guest starred
on Parks and Recreation.
And I was wondering if there's a
relationship between the shows.
And if we might get some guest
stars from Parks and Recreation
to show up on The League like
Aubrey Plaza or anyone else
from the show.
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
Well, I don't think
they're scheduled to
appear on our show at all.
But a bunch of us have
appeared on that show mostly
because we all kind of
came out of the same comedy
background, the
same comedy scene,
a lot of which is built around
the Upright Citizens Brigade
Theatre in New York or LA.
So a lot of us all
are friends or have
relationships with each other.
And I think everybody
just likes to use
each other in those ways.
MARK DUPLASS: There's
fun scenes with Aziz
coming on the show for
fall a few seasons back.
If you haven't seen those,
those are worth checking out.
JASON MANTZOUKAS:
And I'm always trying
to get off from [INAUDIBLE].
Someday.
MARK DUPLASS: But
Offerman, he's a good guy.
I like that guy.
He's--
KATIE ASELTON: No.
He's a great guy.
STEPHEN RANNAZZISI:
He's no Jay Cutler.
I'll tell you that right now.
MARK DUPLASS: I don't know.
MALE SPEAKER: Ladies
and gentlemen,
the cast of The League.
Thank you very much.
MARK DUPLASS: Thank you.